[ __ ] schnitzel is first fried in
plenty of fats until it's crisp and
golden brown then served with slices of
lemon this Viennese specialty is
traditionally accompanied by potato
salad like here in fig al Mulla locals
and visitors start perusing the popular
restaurants menu by late morning there
is always a queue and now finally we
found a weekday when there weren't as
many people we wanted to try a genuine
schnitzel and it was marvelous very
famous for Japanese people so since I'm
in Vienna I lack the necessary something
I eat at least once a week that's the
only real traditional dish I could take
off let's take a look in the kitchen
where the salted meat is being
tenderized dipped in flour and egg yolk
it's then coated in breadcrumbs before
being fried [ __ ] schnitzel really
means a schnitzel made from veal other
variation is made from pork for example
like these have to be called something
else the vom Bakr restaurant looks back
on a long tradition of making schnitzel
members of the imperial court used to
eat here in the early 19th century the
Austrian author Ingrid haslinger knows
how vienna's taste revealed developed as
Wendy originally the upper classes and
the aristocracy were the ones who could
afford feel and poetry too and the
diaries of Archduchess selfies children
franz josef who later became kaiser and
ferdinand max you can already find
indications in 1843 44 that the a
drummer has excellent latest in vampire
how this is Oscar technician in silicon
slow
but ordinary citizens were also
impressed by the aristocracy's elaborate
cuisine which was sometimes garnished
with gold as the story goes they were so
keen to eat golden meat that they coated
their schnitzel with golden brown crumbs
and [ __ ] schnitzel was born vienna's
old city hall is a veritable treasure
trove of old tomes including recipe
books that give valuable insights into
austrian cooking for example that
breadcrumb coatings have long been part
to Viennese cuisine there are recipes
with breaded meat from the end of the
17th century and the coatings that we
are familiar with made from flour
breadcrumbs and egg originated in the
mid 19th century the term veena
schnitzel developed late the first
mention made of it is at the end of the
19th century nowadays the [ __ ]
schnitzel is a staple feature on
Viennese menus the cafe schnitzel Viet
makes a tidy turnover with schnitzel but
because veal is expensive the cheaper
pork version is particularly popular
it's really fresh and really well fried
skip up it's fantastic it's really good
everyone should try it well it is rather
large but if you've got a good appetite
it's fabulous whether it's classic vener
schnitzel or pork schnitzel the dish is
just as much a part of Vienna as the
Viennese Waltz or the ferris wheel in
the Potter fun park
you